let's go ahead
and begin today's webinar i'd like to
introduce paul marca he is the executive
director from the stanford center for
professional development welcome paul
thank you stacy i appreciate it and
uh it's my pleasure to be here with you
today
the stanford center for professional
development has been delivering
education
to people in the world of work for many
many years since 1969
and online since 1997.
we're particularly pleased to be hosting
this webinar and also this course
offered by professor joe boehler
mathematics education here at stanford
and i have to tell you that i have
a secret mission as to why i'm so
excited about this course
i have three small children twins 12
years old and a 10 year old
who desperately need to like math and
currently the
the level of instruction is not good nor
inspiring
dr joe baller is professor of
mathematics education here at stanford
university and it's our pleasure to
welcome her
and the collaboration also with the vice
provost for online learning
here at stanford university we
they have built the course so we are
extending the course out
to as many of those of you who can
attend
both this session and we're now queuing
up another offer
in august uh slated for um offer number
two
uh dr boller is uh here at stanford
in the graduate school of education also
co-founder of you
cubed whose mission it is to harness the
power of new technologies to transform
mathematics education
in the u.s and beyond in order to give
teachers and parents the resources
and ideas they need to inspire and
excite students about
mathematics again why i'm so interested
in this webinar and the course
she's also editor of the research
commentary section of the general
research and mathematics education
and an analyst for the pisa testing in
the oecd
and really the author and creator of the
first mooc on mathematics in teaching
and learning
in times past she has been the marie
curie professor of mathematics education
in england
a mathematics teacher in the london
comprehensive schools and a lecturer and
researcher
at king's college london her phd won a
national award for education and
research
in in the uk and her books uh a number
of books
particularly her latest what's math got
to do with it in 2009
and the elephant in the classroom in
2010 published by souvenir press in the
uk
both aim to increase public
understanding
of the importance of good mathematics
teaching
she serves as an advisor to several
silicon valley companies
including the one she has nurtured you
cubed
and there's been a frequent presenter on
to the white house
in girls and the stem
issues so with that i want to
turn the the floor over to professor joe
buller joe welcome
thank you paul um hello everybody
good afternoon good evening good morning
whatever time
we're in um so first of all i'd just
like to say hello and welcome
um some of you i know will have
probably taken my online course last
summer and it's really good to see you
again if that's the case
some of you may not have done and so i
pitched this
really today to some of it will be
review
uh for those of you who took it some of
it will be new and
if you didn't take it a lot of it will
be new i guess but um
it's been a very interesting year since
uh
the online course that i taught last
summer i've been working
very closely in one particular school
district vista unified
and i'll share some of that i launched
youtube to the non-profit site at the
end of my
online course because so many people
wanted to keep getting the ideas and
i'll tell you more about that later
i was in the white house last week which
is very exciting
i've just finished the online mooc
course for students which i'll show you
a bit later and as paul mentioned i've
been working with pisa
so most i'm really excited and happy
that we're releasing the parent and
teacher course and
later on i'll show you some of the sort
of impact of that which was really great
um i've also been doing lots of parent
meetings and what i want to do is
share a video with you soon that i'm
making to help
for parents who are sort of not
understanding the math changes that are
needed
and i wanted to mention as well i've
made a handout that
every reference i give in this session
and all of the links i give
are on that handout so you can go to the
website later if you want so i want to
start actually with a question for you
and that is it would really help me in
talking to you if i know
who did actually take the online course
last summer so perhaps you could answer
the poll
and if you took any of it please say yes
and if you didn't take any of it say no
and then
also i have a question about whether
you're what a teacher or a parent or
work in some other way so if you could
answer that poll now that would be great
thank you
so i think we're going to get the
answers to the polls pretty immediately
so um we can all have a look at those i
think
um let's have a look all right so um
pretty almost evenly split so i met some
about a third of the people did take the
online class that was interesting and
really evenly
split amongst the different levels of
school so great i love that we have all
different grade levels
um and a few and some parents as well so
i'm going to begin i thought i'd share
with you a picture i took in the white
house last week
so you're probably thinking now did i
really take that photograph in the white
house i did really take that photograph
from the white house but
it was cheating a little because um the
president was in china at the time and
that's actually a photograph of a
photograph in the white house but
i think it's a really nice photo so i
thought i'd share that with you so i
anyway i'm going to begin today by
briefly just for five minutes going
through the sort of basic
ideas behind the changes that i think we
need to make which for some of you will
be a review
and then after that i'm going to get
into my favorite teaching strategies for
you
so the big idea that i've been talking a
lot about
is um this thing that we suffer from
in the us which i describe to people as
the elephant in the classroom and
you know the expression the elephant in
the room which refers to an idea that
everybody's thinking about but nobody
talks about and i argue that there's a
big elephant standing in most math
classrooms in the us
and in other countries and that is the
idea that only some kids can be good at
math
teachers believe that parents believe it
and students believe it
and that single idea is at the root of a
lot of the
underachievement in the u.s and i think
as math teachers we have to deal with
this
myth that's out there that being good at
math is some kind of a gift and that
some people are naturally good at math
some are not
so we have decades now of research
really
solid research that shows that is
completely false you're not born with a
math gift nobody's born with that
and everybody in fact can achieve at
high levels in school it's
to do with the experiences people have
from birth
and it's also really important how kids
think about this the ideas they have
about their own ability
and their own potential so you probably
know
calderec released a book which was a new
york times bestseller
in which she summarized her research
from a number of years which shows that
people have
one of two mindsets so if you have a
growth mindset
you believe that the more work you do
the smarter you get
but if you have a fixed mindset you
believe that you're either smarter
you're not and it turns out about half
of kids have a fixed mindset
in mathematics and that mindset really
harms their learning
so we also know um
that these different mindsets go along
with different behaviors so
kids with a growth mindset are more
persistent
they're willing to learn from mistakes
they're very determined to keep going
and they're encouraged by each other's
success
kids with a fixed mindset are those
could you you probably know in your
classroom where you give them some
challenging math work to do
and they'll immediately say i can't do
this i need help
we know that fixed mindset thinking
affects students from across the
achievement spectrum
and in fact high achieving girls are
some of the worst hit by fixed mindset
beliefs and we also know that praise is
really important
in giving these different mindsets and
the way that many kids in the u.s have a
fixed mindset is because
as parents in the us we often praise
kids for being smart
so when they do something good we say
you're really smart and what
ki we now know kids process about this
is at first they think oh good i'm
really smart but then when they fail
and they will later they think oh i'm
not so smart
and it starts to set up this fixed ideas
in carol's latest research they found
that the praise given to babies
between the age of zero and three
predicts their mindset
five years later so very important
around the way we speak the kids and
this graph just shows you
kids students were given a survey at the
beginning of seventh grade to see which
mindset they had
and the line that goes on the bottom is
the kids with a fixed mindset and
you know they just followed kids over
the next year or two to look at their
achievement and
those are the growth mindset of the ones
that go onwards and upwards
so we also know that mindset has very
important implications for equity
mindset interventions have the greatest
impact on
for students of color and for girls and
as i said
fixed mindset thinking is much more
prevalent amongst high achieving girls
and in fact
the reason i was at the white house was
i was um
reporting to the council on women and
girls about girls in stem
and i talked about some of this the
importance of mindset for girls and
the paper i handed out at the at the
white house is on
youtube and you can see that in the
handout
so as was mentioned i've been working
with the pisa team
over the last few months which is really
exciting you probably know the pisa team
give international math surveys every
four years
but they also collect a lot of data on
students ideas about math and themselves
and so this data hasn't um
really been released a lot yet we're
writing some things up but
it turns out that the mindset kids have
are hugely important and
also the way they approach math is
really important as we all know
and in fact the kids who say that they
memorize
so when they approach matha their their
approach is to try and remember lots of
things are the lowest achieving kids in
the world
the kids who come into math saying
they're thinking about the big ideas
are the highest achievers and what we
can see from this graph
is the huge difference for the kids with
a fixed
and a growth mindset so
the kids with a growth mindset are the
highest achieving kids this is from 13
million
15 year olds and those with the highest
achievement in the world
are those with a growth mindset and that
use these good strategies
the sort of strategies that i discuss
and highlight
in the teacher course so um
i'm going to talk about five key
strategies today
and um they fall around these four big
things that are all really important to
teachers around how we group how we
assess and grade
the tasks we give and what we do with
mistakes so
it's my view that the two biggest
changes we need to make in u.s
mathematics education
the first one is we have to get students
believing that they can achieve at the
highest levels of mathematics which many
don't now
and then we also have to engage them
actively with mathematics and we know
that when we get kids problem solving
talking about mathematics reasoning
through problems
they achieve at higher levels so they're
really important and
particularly the role of mathematical
discussions
so we know that you know contrary to
common belief that the best way to study
math is to be alone with a book
we know that when kids talk about math
it gives them access to a deeper level
of understanding
but there's another reason to have kids
talk about math and something that i'm
talking to parents about when they're
opposing the common core
so what i'm finding is a lot of people
have high achieving kids are saying
uh why should my why should my child
explain their methods
they can get the work right why are they
having to explain their methods
and what i say to them is explaining
methods
is what in mathematical language we
would call reasoning
is really the core of what mathematics
is so when a scientist proves something
they they look at it in a number of
different cases
but for mathematicians they actually
reason their way through to proof
and it's the core of the discipline
um and i wrote an article about that
which appeared in the atlantic
last year and if you have parents who
are
needing to understand both and teachers
too
the the ways to change the way we think
about kids and how to get rid of
the stereotypes and also the importance
of reasoning then
you can find that article and the link
is in the handout
so i'm going to start off by talking
about grouping
we know that discussion is really
important
discussion in whole class discussions
discussions small group discussions
but it's often derailed as teachers
know through unequal participation
so what can happen often in group work
is
one student will do all the work another
one will be left out
somebody else chooses to check out and
that isn't the way good group work works
so i'm curious and i'll put this in a
poll in a minute how many
of you know about this but an approach
to group work that i've
found to be associated with high
achievement as of other researchers
is one called complex instruction so
complex instruction
starts from the basis that you have to
make group work equal
and you have to counter status
differences to do that
and they do it and you can do this in
any subject at any grade level
by giving the students roles by teaching
a broader
what i would call multi-dimensional
mathematics by giving and by giving
different messages about who can achieve
so um the approach was designed by
rachel lotan and liz cohen and if you
want to read more about it
there's a great book in it designing
group work the yellow one has been out
for some years and is available now
they're actually just re-released the
book um but if you want the re-release
version that's coming out in july
and that's on your sheet but anyway now
i'm
i want to come up to my first strategy
which is something i've really come to
love over the past
year so um
it's this is really new but it's i'll
tell you about that but before i do i
just i'm curious about whether any of
you've
used the approach of complex instruction
at any time so there's a poll now coming
up have you ever used
the strategy of complex instruction when
grouping kids
so i'll just wait and for a few while
people answer that
okay so i think we're going to see
okay so we have 16 of people have used
it at some time
62 percent uh have not used it and
22 we don't know so um
if you would like to to learn more about
that approach then those books
and also articles on youtube will help
you with that
but there's something particular they do
inside comics instruction that i'm going
to teach you
before i do that some other things we
talked about in the course was the way
we assess and grade kids
obviously the way kids get feedback on
their work
hugely impacts their mindset and one of
the things we talk about in the online
course is how
replacing grades with diagnostic
comments
is really a positive thing for students
engagement so
we tend to grade a lot in the us in
other countries kids get a grade at the
end of the year
and what we know is from studies is that
when teachers stop grading altogether
and give diagnostic comments telling
kids what they need to do to improve
achievement really goes up so but i know
as well and i
you know from all the work i do with
teachers that particularly teachers in
the u.s feel that their hands are tied
and
they have to be grading a lot because
the school administration requires it
parents require it the streets require
it so
one of the things that i recommend for
them
is to switch the grading so instead of
grading always being on
sort of how many answers are correct
actually grade on the participation you
want to see in the classroom
and once you start grading on that kids
participation drastically
improves so this leads me to my first
strategy which i'm really loving at the
moment so
this is something called a participation
quiz and those of you who know
confidence instruction may know this
strategy
so i taught this to the teachers i work
with in vista school district
and they did the participation quest the
first day
with a group and they tell me by the
time the groups met for the second time
it had
transformed the way kids worked in
groups
so the way it works is students work in
a group on some math work
and they are literally graded the group
is graded at the end of the lesson for
their participation in the group work
so the teachers are actually looking for
how they participate
are they leaning in and talking to each
other are they asking good questions
um are they working equally
so i'm going to take you through how to
run a participation quiz
it would be much better if we could
watch videos and talk about this in a pd
session but i'm hoping this
will help to just try it once and see
what happens
so this is how you run one you just
choose an orderly uh day of group work
where kids are working on math tasks
together
and then you tell kids they're going to
get a grade for how they work in the
group at the end of the lesson
and then it's very important you show
students what you're looking for in
their group work
so the example i'm going to show you the
teachers share
with students we're looking for these
kind of interactions and we're looking
for this kind of mathematical work
now then you either get a piece of paper
or some teachers do it on the board
publicly on on a whatever form of
display
into sections for each group so
if you have 32 students and work in
groups of four which complex instruction
recommends
you might have eight sections and as
students are working on their groups
teachers circulate the room just
writing down comments inside the boxes
for each group
how well they're working any good
questions that come up
and then at the end of the lesson they
assign each group a grade
so um the teachers i work with
i'm just pulling their slides that they
have used for complex for a
participation quiz
just to give you an idea but they showed
to the students before these
so this is the mathematical slide
there's a lot on here i'm not sure i
would use
as many particularly for younger kids
you might want to highlight two things
so this shows you a full range of things
the sort of things you could put up here
but
so they say we want you to be
recognizing describing patterns
justifying thinking using multiple
representations
making connections between different
approaches and representations
using words arrows numbers and color
coding to communicate
ideas clearly explain ideas clearly to
team members and the teacher
ask questions to understand the thinking
of other team members
ask questions that push the group to go
deeper and
organize a presentation so that people
outside the group can understand your
group's
thinking and sort of the mantra of
complex instruction
that the teachers use with it is this
message to kids
no one is good at all of these things
but everyone is good at something
and you need all of your group members
to be successful
so these are the kind of mathematical
things they're looking for and then
the teachers had very concrete thing
group
behavior we're looking for you to be
leaning in and working in the middle of
the table so a nice strategy for group
work
is a sort of tip really is to only have
one
work piece of paper because if kids have
their own paper they're very likely to
pull off to the side and work on it so
one piece of one task paper are they
leaning in and work in the middle of the
table
is there equal air time are they
sticking together are they listening to
each other
are they asking each other lots of
questions and then following the team
roles
so as a teacher i might have a sheet
something like this and walk around
making notes on the clipboard or as i
said
i might have it at the front of the room
and i'm just going to share with you an
example of one teacher's
notes at the end of a participation quiz
so you can see
they're both they've graded the groups
but also um
at some points they've just said great
discussion working well together
building on each other's ideas sometimes
there's a question written down that
they
is a quote from the kids can anyone see
a different way
you can see the bottom left-hand group
weren't working so well together
talking about clothes off task so
what happened with the teachers that i
work with in vista school district is
they tried a participation quiz one day
and they told the the kids were going to
be grading on a group work they went
down making notes
and i guess the kids didn't really pay
much that attempt pay much attention to
that
and at the end of the day they gave them
grades and talked about it
but what they said was the next time
they did group work the very next time
the kids interactions in the groups had
massively improved
so they're really loving using this as a
group work strategy
so this is a quick overview but i'm
curious and i put in another poll here
to see
my question is do you think you would
try a participation quiz one thing i can
do is put up more detailed instructions
on youtube
if you would like so maybe i'll just
stop for a minute
while you can fill that question out do
you think we you would
try one of these
all right so i think we have
the results and we'll just wait a little
while
and we'll all have a look at what you
might think about participation quizzes
all right great so lots of people are
interested in trying
that's great so um i'd be really
interested if you try it
to hear what happens so you could email
me
i have a twitter account i'd love to
know
if you try these out what happens over
the next
sort of times of doing group work so um
my next thing i want to talk about a
little bit is classroom math tasks so
in the teacher online course we spend
quite a bit of time on tasks and
thinking about
what makes a really good task for
students
i argue that it's very hard to have a
growth mindset in math
when all you work on in math class is a
series of short closed questions that
you either get right or wrong
so those kind of questions don't convey
to kids that math is about learning
and in fact we know that a lot of
students
actually don't think that they're in
math class
to learn they think that they're there
to perform and they'll tell you that
when they go into math class
what's important is to get questions
right so they're not
so oriented around learning as much as
performance and this
really came home to me recently when a
colleague of mine rachel lambert
told me her six-year-old son came home
one day and said
he hadn't liked math class and she said
why you know what happened and he said
math is too much answer time and not
enough learning time
so that's a really perceptive comment
from a six-year-old but you know you can
see how kids get this impression that
they go into math class and they're
answering questions so what i do in my
work with teachers and we talked about
in the teaching course
is tasks need to give students the space
inside them to learn something if a task
really is just answering a question that
doesn't really have space for learning
so
i shared this framework we've developed
for
growth mindset tasks they need to focus
on learning and have opportunities to
learn
something inside them
so to do this the main thing is to open
up math tasks
and you can open them in different ways
you can have a task where you ask
kids how they see it and i'll show you
an example in a minute
you can have tasks with multiple entry
points tasks
that value different pathways and
strategies tasks that focus on sense
making rather than an
answer um and i'll we'll look at a
little example
um so this example comes from a
wonderful teacher kathy humphries
and it's actually in a book of
video cases of her teaching her seventh
grade class
so it's called the book's called
connecting mathematical ideas but
one divided by two thirds is could
totally be a closed
one answer question that students just
answer but she opens it up
by focusing on sense making so what she
says to them is not
get the answer to one divided by
two-thirds she asked them for the answer
and then
ask the students how to make sense of
their answer with a representation
so what you get from that is there a
very there are many different ways of
seeing the problem and students have
different methods and different
representations
so um the
many of the kids in the class got the
answer six
you know do something with two and three
comes out with six
and but then they really struggled to
make sense of that
so kathy uses this in the classroom i
really like this and it's really good
for the common core
and it comes from a book by
some english authors actually where they
talk about
telling students as a three-stage
process really three levels or three
standards of a convincing argument now
kids need to be making convincing
arguments with the new common core
and what they say is that the lowest
standard is when you convince yourself
we're usually pretty easy to convince
ourselves
the next level up is when you convince a
friend and that third level up is when
you convince a skeptic
actually in the book they say convince
an enemy and kathy changed it to a
skeptic i think
um anyway she has asked the kids
to be skeptics and i did this actually
just this past week with a group of
teachers it was great and i said okay we
really got to be skeptics you've got to
push
any antsy there any reasoning to make
sure it completely makes sense to be
very skeptical how do you know that how
do we
kids love being a skeptic you can get
them all to be skeptics with each other
and they take on that
role really readily but it's also
really helpful in pushing other students
to convince and reason so very
mathematical things too
so i wanted to tell you about a
wonderful task that helps kids be more
convincing and in fact i use this task
just last week with the role of the
skeptic where some people had to
convince others and the others were
skeptics so
this isn't the whole task but the whole
task is on youtube
um and it comes from
mark driscoll and it's a book called
fostering geometric thinking and it's a
paper folding task
this is one of my favorites and i think
this is great for lots of age levels
so they i'm only showing you a little
extract of the whole task but they start
with a square piece of paper
and they have to do all these different
constructions and just one of them's up
here constructs another square
with half of the area but that's
oriented differently from the one you
constructed in four there's a whole list
of questions
explain how you know it has half of the
area
so this is a great task kids actually
have to make this and fold their square
and then they have to be really
convincing that they know that this is a
square
so what you see as they do this is their
push to be very precise to be very
mathematical to use the right words
particularly if you have other people
being skeptics
so i love that task on youtube there's a
high school unit so there's three
units on youtube at the moment one for
elementary one middle and
one high the high school one actually is
one we wrote here at stanford and it's
over 100 pages of great activities
and this paper folding activity is one
of them it's on page 87 so if you want
to go to that task
you can buy the book from heinemund and
the link's there and it's it's a great
book
or you can get the task in that way so
um
an example of something
that i want to share with you now comes
from a five-week algebra class that i
actually talk with my graduate students
in summer school
so it was a summer school seventh and
eighth grade kids who were mainly
under achieving and we our goal in
teaching the class was to teach
algebra as a problem-solving tool and we
drew from different places for our tasks
ruth parker
mark driscoll some english schemes but
one of the things we did was we kept all
of the tasks open
and we actually got amazing
participation from the kids my book
what's mascot to do with it
describes what happened in the summer
school in more detail on the tasks
but we basically gave them a lot of
algebraic pattern tasks they hadn't
learned algebra and they learned algebra
through that
and did really well in algebra
afterwards but and we kept the task open
so i wanted to share with one stress
one issue that teachers have is kids
always at work at different levels they
are
at different achievement levels they
work at different speeds and one thing i
like to do in my own teaching with kids
is always to have a strategy at my
sleeve
which is to get any kids who finish
to either extend the task they're given
or ask a new question
so this has happened a lot in summer
school
and this is one example we gave the kids
this task but and there are two ways to
give this task
find the total number of blocks in a
hundred block high
staircases is a kind of traditional way
of asking that question
the way i like to ask it and you may
have seen
before is asking people how the shape
grows
visually and from there they get to the
hundred block question but
much more conceptually but anyway we
asked when kids finished we just said
okay you
now over to you you come up with your
own question one of the boys who had got
all f's in math class
um came up with this lovely extension
which is much
harder conceptually where they were
looking at staircases and all the kids
started doing this so
my strategy really around this is
whenever you're working with short math
questions with long
math questions great strategy for kids
is when they get to the end
just say to them now over to you
you write a question and try and make it
a hard question
and then have kids give their questions
to each other it involves kids in a much
deeper way
it helps them with mathematics it helps
them in all sorts of ways so i really
like
that strategy but so
generally we know that when math tasks
are more open opened up for different
ways of seeing different pathways
different representations
the opportunities for learning and for
developing a growth mindset are
increased
so a couple of other things to share
just before we finish um
not going to say much about speed other
than we do know that math should not be
associated with speed and the article
you see there
just came out in nctm's journal and is
also
downloadable on youtube about the damage
caused by time tests
so just a mention of that but what i
want to finish on
the last couple of strategies is i
shared in
in the teacher class and we spend a bit
of time discussing
how i teach these classes for
teaching math for a growth mindset and
carol dweck came into the first one and
said something which
shocked all the math teachers which was
every time a student makes a mistake in
math a synapse fires
and actually we have new research
evidence just from the past year that
shows
that when kids make a mistake in math
brain growth occurs
electric stimuli fire in their brain but
when they get work correct
no brain growth happens and they don't
have to go back and correct the mistake
which a lot of people think it's really
the point of struggle that causes that
brain growth
so this has huge implications for us i
think as math teachers it means we
really want
students making mistakes mistakes
are when their brains are growing the
most but they need to feel
safe in the environment to do that and
know that mistakes are valued
really great for teachers just to start
the years saying
i love mistakes mistakes when your
brains grow
i want to see mistakes you'd be amazed
how much that puts kids at ease
mathematically
so here's my full strategy this actually
came from a teacher in the online class
so
in the mistakes session i asked people
to design a sort of
new way of handling mistakes in the
classroom and i'd love to know who the
teacher was who suggested this
if you're listening perhaps you could
email me but one of the teachers in the
class
submitted her idea and she said this she
said at the start of classes now she
gets
kids to scramble up a piece of paper and
throw it
at the board with the feelings they have
when they make a mistake
and then she gets them to unfold the
paper
and draw a little brain on it and then
just draw over and color
all the lines from the crumpled up paper
and that represents all the synaptic
firing of making a mistake and she gets
kids to keep that
to remind them another thing i loved
comes from one of the teachers in vista
kim hollowell who took from the course
all the messages that came from the
course about the value of mistakes and
other things
and she asked kids to cut to design a
picture of their own brains and you can
see there
or they were told about the parts of the
brain that sort of see in black and
white in color
and so they each design their own brain
and they put their favorite message
on it so it's a beautiful visual and you
can see some of their different messages
they cho
the kids chose easy is a waste of time
i don't know this yet embracing struggle
i can grow my mouth brain
lots of things so um
a couple of things about the future just
to finish off
i will be uploading on youtube within
the next month we just
have funding for youtube and so we're
just finally putting lots of new stuff
up there and
a video for parents explaining why high
achievers need
to be in classrooms with others and
and working on these ideas and other
things so look out for that
so um the online class which some of you
took
is now re-released by stanford it
actually was amazing last summer it
really surpassed all my
expectations 40 000 people registered
and at the end
92 percent of people said they were very
or extremely satisfied with the course
95 so they would change their teaching
as a result of the course or ways of
helping their own kids
and they did that i had thousands of
emails from people great emails
detailing
the changes they'd made and how it had
changed their students so
the course is up again um
stanford is charging for it at this
point it's 125 dollars it
you can take it and get a certifi a sort
of certificate for your school
the schools i hope will pay for this or
districts and we know that some
districts
um well paper teachers all give them
salary advancement so if you want to
take the course
uh it's open now you can go up and
register also
we're releasing a student mooc so these
are things to get the ideas straight to
students
six short 15 minute sessions
designed to improve students
relationships with math give them a
growth mindset
features my undergrads help me present
it i'll show you a little bit
and that's designed for students of any
age the details of that on the handout
too so in fact i'm just going to show
you a little minute
clip from the student clause that we
have
more details um so more details for that
are on the handout
um and then youtube is the non-profit
site i started last year just to keep
these ideas up for teachers
it has a number and parents it has a
number of sections on it section for
parents for teachers there are different
units on it some videos
details of the moocs if you sign up with
your email
for that you'll get newsletters and
there's going to be a new
really different full of ideas site in
the next month
so if you're signed up with your account
through school and you want to get new
ideas over the summer
you might want to sign up with a
personal email but if you go to the
bottom of the site it just asks you to
give your name
and to do a math problem that's so they
know you're not an alien somebody
tweeted me and said they were glad it
wasn't timed it's not timed but
if you fill in your email you'll get all
those great things that are going to
come up in the summer
and then um we have a little clip of the
teacher course too
to show you so you can get an idea of
the sort of things we work on in the
teacher course so we're going to show
you that now
all right so we've had some questions
come in we'll just spend the last few
moments on answering a few questions
um so ken asked a really great question
about automaticity
the question is how if we don't have
time tests do we develop
automaticity well we know that time
tests actually don't encourage
automaticity that
fast kids stay fast and let slow kids
stay slow
and that article on youtube does
show talk about other ways of developing
mental math and automaticity
so definitely go to that as a resource
for that
dirk asked the number of people who
finished the teaching mooc actually it
was
uh 40 of people got right to the end
and i think the people who are actively
engaged was higher than that
because many teachers it ended just
before the school year started uh just
after the school year started so i know
lots of people only got through about
half of it
so now's the chance to get to the other
half but yes so but still
great great participation mode much
higher than other
moocs um i'm looking at other questions
now so um
i'm not sure how to pronounce this la
wana perhaps
asked how the grouping strategy be
adapted for very small classes or
multiple grade level classes
so i think conflict instruction is
really great the more diverse the class
is
actually we know it works well when
classes are very different the kids are
very different
better than when they're all high or all
achieving at low
levels so great if it's multi-age it
works in small classes too um
somebody says should you jump from
having students in rows to doing a
four-person
group would it be easier to start with
pairs of students and can i do the
participation quiz with
pairs i think the participation quiz
would be hard with page you could try it
i mean
i'm all for trying things in the
classroom and
and seeing what happens and learning
from them you probably can
get good participation happening with
two but ideally i would go to four
people groups and
the communist instruction book really
gives you some tasks to start with that
really
need all four people so i think you can
go from rows to four
in a group it's amazing how well how
good students are actually at
um engaging in groups particularly they
have set roles
how do you convince lenders asking how
do you convince teachers to take the
time to support discourse and reasoning
when they're focused on how many
standards
and the depth to which they must teach
those standards in a typical school year
so discourse and reasoning are a big
part of the common core standards
and you probably know if you've tried
some of the new tests that are coming
out they also assess
discourse and reasoning and kids can no
longer be successful
choosing a b c or d they have to explain
their methods so
it's very important for their
achievement it's also extremely
mathematical
it is the future that kids need
we know that the biggest growing job in
the us is somebody who's a data analyst
all the new companies in the u.s have a
large amount of data
and people need to be able to ask
questions of the data
and reason through different
presentations they give so that other
people can access
it's a very important thing and
discourse and reasoning
the cherry on the cake really give
students better access to understanding
and help them achieve
at higher levels what's
um so the question about automatically
without speed drills i i
mentioned going to that paper to see
some but the other thing i recommend is
if you want kids to practice the math
there's nothing wrong with practicing
math practice is important
but i i recommend they do that on
engaging apps and
games um we have one developed at
stanford called was it
trouble which is a really nice app
motion math is really nice
um there are all sorts there are lots of
bad math apps and games out there
actually
um and so i try and sort of recommend
ones in fact
in the teacher course there's a section
on which apps and math
apps and games are good but that's a
good way to practice and it's much more
engaging
um for kids
so somebody says can you talk about math
linda can you talk about math
disabilities and does it have a fit
does having a fixed mindset have a role
in that absolutely it has a role in that
and i think
a lot of kids there are kids who have
particularly special needs and then
their kids have just been traumatized by
math
and actually it's hard a lot of the time
to separate those kids
um most kids who are achieving
at low levels do have a fixed mindset um
and so working on mindset with those
kids
has a huge impact and it has the biggest
impact on those kids so
definitely um what are the dates for the
summer teacher course
and will we have access to notes for
today's webinar
so the teacher course is open for
registration now
um it's the classes will officially open
on june the 16th
and stay open and what we're looking
into doing is having the first cohort so
it opens on june 16th
stays open until mid-september and then
maybe
a second registration if people want to
take it
later august and go through to later in
the fall
that one but at the moment it's open you
can register now
and do so
somebody andrea can you speak about when
you're the only person in your school
that believes all this
how do you keep your spirits up when the
structure doesn't value what you feel is
critical
yeah i absolutely feel you um andrea
that's a really hard situation to be in
it's always great to have colleagues
what's wonderful about the new
technological age we live in
is you can find those colleagues and
have those colleagues
through connections technologically
youtube is going to start having a lot
of teacher community on it so i would
recommend signing
up there the teacher course the teachers
stayed together
so i guess we've run out of time but
thanks very much for joining joining me
and yeah we will send out notes from
this
later joe thank you very much for a
wonderful webinar and a more terrific
course your commitment comes through
loud and clear and i believe that uh and
everyone will benefit from this both
parents teachers
at various levels thank you all for
joining us and we wish you a good day
wherever you are